[Applause]
those protesters illegally occupying
parliament grounds and surrounding
streets have been given ample
opportunity to leave
it is time for them to go
as the police commissioner said this
morning it's time to clear the roads and
restore order for wellingtonians
it will be obvious to those who work in
and around parliament that the protest
has been at times violent and
increasingly fueled by misinformation
and sadly conspiracy theories it has
also become a location of interest we
know covert has circulated within the
protest and they have been
hospitalizations as a result
whatever point the protesters were
making at the beginning was made but it
is time for it to end
in the last week we've seen a changing
mix in the makeup of the crowd
in particular we've become concerned
that those with good intentions
are now outnumbered by those with a
willingness to use violence to affect
their means
we have observed an escalation and
concerning behaviour
which has ultimately resulted in today's
action
[Music]
in the
[Music]
oh my morning
[Music]